Reasons for job changes can be various.
Whether it's the bad atmosphere at work, differences with superiors, lack of career perspectives...
...or dissatisfaction with the salary, a move should be well planned.
It's important that you do not give notice before you have secured a new job.
However, it might not be the best practice to rub it in,...
...because your boss might be offended.
There is no formula to determine the right moment.
Many employers think that the time has come...
...when you are experienced in routinely fulfilling your duties.
However, you have to remember that it will not be enough to carry out duties routinely.
You will probably be expected to come up with innovations.
See if there are ways to develop new skills within your present job.
You could also consider a sideways move within your industry...
...where your present knowledge comes in handy.
For example, if you are a programmer,...
...you could look at technical sales or project management.